>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Good evening, everyone.
Welcome. Glad you can make it.
My name is Larry Appelbaum.
I'm one of the music
specialists here
in the Music Division
of the Library.
I think everyone is gathered
here tonight in anticipation
with this concert we're
about to hear.
And it is with great pleasure that
I'm going to take a few minutes
to talk with the composer,
the arranger,
and the band leader,
Maria Schneider.
Please help me welcome her.
[ Applause ]
So here we are and we're about
90 minutes before show time.
What kind of things
go through your mind?
Do you have like a
checklist of things
that you have to do before concert?
>> Maria Schneider:
Well, it depends,
like tonight we're playing a
piece called "Cerulean Skies"
that has bird calls and
I don't have my people
from the audience that participate.
There is supposed to be
birds around the room.
So, I'm like, OK.
Somebody said we have to
hermetically seal the bird calls
or putting tape around them so
that people don't get germs.
[ Laughter ]
You know, those kind of-- There's
a lot of logistical things.
And then there is talking
to somebody in the band
because we're doing a premiere,
you know, so talking about, "Hey,
when you do that line,
can you try this?"
You know, just always a few
little last minute details.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Speaking
of this premier tonight,
Maria has been commissioned
to write a new work
and you will be the first
audience to hear it.
Why don't you tell us a
little about the piece itself,
what context it comes out of, and
maybe something about the music?
>> Maria Schneider: OK.
So, whenever I get a commission, I--
I don't know, I almost
panic a little bit,
feel a lot of pressure,
you know, torture.
And I started working
on this and writing
and there were a few
things that came to me.
One was that as I was
working on it, the--
it was a little bit of a different
sound and a different approach
and a different something that--
than what I had before and
I immediately recognized
that it was the influence of having
worked with David Bowie a year
and a half before and the project
that we did and the kind of attitude
and the sense of freedom
and fun and risk-taking
that he made me feel
very comfortable doing
and kind of that he reveled in.
So, it's got some of that
and it's got the intensity.
He really liked my
intense dark music.
And it kind of made me
explore that dark side.
But then as I as writing
it, also at the same time,
many of you maybe know or if
you don't know, I will tell you,
I'm quite into the whole thing
of what is happening right now
in our digital world and
rights for music creators
and creators of all kinds.
But specifically my interest from
my perspective is music creation
and this idea that there are
these companies that are sort
of seducing us with the
idea of seducing musicians
that exposure is wonderful,
seducing everybody that, you know,
more is better and this concept that
free is just the way it has to be.
But it's very conveniently-- it's
very convenient that the people
that are making it free are actually
becoming very, very rich off of it.
There's a massive redistribution
of wealth to these small companies
that are becoming huge and
they are big data companies.
And, you know, we're talking
like Alphabet, Google, YouTube
and this kind on inducement of
infringement to gather this data.
And this data is making
these companies
like Google more and more powerful.
And there are people and
scientists and people that speculate
that by the year 2035, artificial
intelligence could become more
intelligent than we are.
And actually, that
could be catastrophic.
You know, some say utopian,
some say catastrophic
and it could go different
directions.
For-- I can tell you for the
music industry right now, it--
or not the industry,
the music makers,
the people that make the music
because you have the music industry,
you have the internet, big data--
and the piece I wrote
is called "Data Lords".
So the data lords, but
what they're resting on
and how they're attracting people
to amass all these data
is on the music creator.
You know, that's the
attractor, make that free
and then you get all these eyeballs
and then you get the information
of how people move around.
So, the piece is about the seduction
and then this gathering of data.
So there's this intensity that
comes through and it just kind
of overtakes us at the end.
[ Laughter ]
We'll see.
So, "Data Lords", yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
"Data Lords", yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: So, and also,
as I was writing, I thought, well,
this is perfect, you know?
I'm going to Library
of Congress, you know?
Oh, there's a copyright, you know?
It's like OK, Washington D.C., this
is a good place to unleash my--
the holy hell of the data lords.
[ Laughter ]
>> Larry Appelbaum: It's interesting
to hear you talk about that,
because I want to know what
choices a creative artist has today
when faced with these things.
I mean, you talk about the
seduction of promotion,
for example, or exposure.
Well, of course, when people
are starting out, they need--
in fact, they feel
they must have that.
But what real choices do people
have other than to be co-opted?
>> Maria Schneider:
The-- For me, I'm--
I would say that I'm one of the
few musicians that has managed
in this climate of what's going on,
and I became very inoculated
before it really hit luckily
because a friend of mine started
this company called ArtistShare.
And the whole idea is that the
artist owns their own work,
the artist sells directly to
the fan through the internet
and through ArtistShare that
they share all the data.
So when somebody buys my music or--
you know, through my
site, I know who they are.
It's not some other company using
that data but it's my information.
And the idea is that I
am not just sharing music
but I'm sharing the
whole creative process.
So whenever I do a project,
I announce I'm going
to be doing a project.
I don't have to start
from square one each time
because I have amass this fan base
now, because I've been doing project
after project, commissions
and recordings, and recordings
that are $200,000, and
managing to pay for them
because of this relationship
that I've made.
So, for me and what I tell all
musicians now is self-ownership is
king, having your own
relationship with those people
that you establish, that
relationship of trust and respect,
giving them things that are fun.
So they feel like, you know, wow,
this is so much more special than,
you know, just going and
streaming something somewhere.
Wow, I'm getting this
whole inside story.
And it's fun for me.
The connection is beautiful
because it's-- Yeah, so it's that.
And then the other thing is there
is a group of us in New York
that have started, you know, a
campaign called Musicanswers.org.
And one thing that's
happening in this--
in the music industry and even
with people that, you know, lobby,
Congress and everything, is that
some of the music organizations
that are doing it, they
are doing wonderful work
but there is a little
bit of a problem
and that sometimes the record
companies and the publishers are
in those organizations with
the people that make the music.
And some of those record companies
and publishers have actually
joined the data lords.
You know, Sony, Universal,
Warner all took equity--
and Spotify, Spotify is a data lord.
You know, they're making music free
to attract eyeballs to amass data
and sell advertising and
with a lack of transparency.
So the idea that we had
was to start this campaign
where we educate musicians and
people, any-- all of you can join.
You can go and sign up and just
say, "I'm a fan of the music,
I'm in the music industry," or
"I'm a composer, a songwriter,
a producer or performer."
That's who we're advocating for.
So we have videos up about YouTube.
We're going to have things
you should always have
in a publishing contract,
language you should never have
in a publishing contract, the
idea of empowering musicians
because we have been sitting ducks
for so long because, first of all,
we love what we do and what we most
want is that you love what we do.
So, if you-- if many musicians
will just give it away just
to be appreciated, and of course,
you know, industry looks at this
and say, "What a bunch
of idiots," you know?
And to some extent, musicians
and artists, there was a history
of feeling like you're-- that
if you are the starving artist,
there is something-- that's
an incredible story, you know?
So it's like, wow, they
actually feel more special
when they're a starving
artist, excellent, you know?
[ Laughter ]
You know, let's use them up
and suck them dry, you know?
So this is-- So to me, it's
education and it's very difficult
to move Congress and, you
know, the Subcommittee
on Intellectual Property
is very difficult to move
that when you've got buildings of
lobbyists from Google and YouTube
and this revolving door between
government and these companies.
But, if the-- if you have the
power of this list of names--
and we have Carole King,
we have Herbie Hancock,
we have so many people now, you
know, just a lot of musicians
and students and everybody.
And if we're all getting
this knowledge
and we're saying we are
watching you and we do not
like what you're doing,
suddenly there's a shame factor.
And so sometimes, I think that the
strongest change you can make is
that, you know?
And then everything has to change,
you know, rather than mandating it
through law, but yes,
I would like the law
to change regarding
the digital rights
and Safe Harbor Rules
and all these things.
But, you know, you have
to be reasonable, too,
and we don't know what can change.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Every time
I hear you speak about this
and others, I wonder who
really owns the music.
We often prefer to believe
that the creators do,
the people who actually dream up
or even manufacturer or record
or whatever it might be,
that creative process.
But who really does own the music?
>> Maria Schneider:
Well, I guess it--
I mean to me, the person
that creates the music,
the copyright holder, the
person who makes the music.
I mean if you-- there
is that other level too
that you can copyright a recording.
But, you know, the
thing that people forget
and I think what's
happened is as we've gotten
from the physical product-- and a
guy, Marshall Gilkes, in my band,
he just did a panel about this.
And he came up with an incredible
point that I hadn't thought about.
He said, "You know, it
wasn't that long ago
when Tower Records said
they would wrap those CDs
in those plastic things that
would beep when you would go out
and the cop would arrest you
if you stole that, you know?"
So what is the difference
between that
and grabbing the file somewhere?
So, you know, I think people have
come to think that if music is
out there, that sort of
ephemeral, beautiful thing,
it's all of ours, it's
so easy to access.
But it is an asset.
You know, when you write
that music, the investment.
When I made my last
recording, "Thompson Fields",
it's a $200,000 recording.
Just recording it, you know,
the planning of it, the mixing--
the editing, the mixing,
the mastering,
the putting the book
together, it was a full year
where I couldn't really work
and make money that much
because I was doing that.
So that $200,000 doesn't
include that I wasn't paid.
Now, we haven't talked
about the years proceeding
up to it writing all the music.
So we're talking like
a $400,000 investment.
That's an asset.
That's my 401(k), right?
[ Laughter ]
So this is like-- you
know, I remember Congress.
I just-- I wanted to look at
them and just say, just imagine--
because I got to testify
before the Subcommittee
on Intellectual Property.
And I didn't get the chance to say
it, but I wanted to say, imagine if,
you know, we build some kind of
app that could go on to your 401(k)
that was just like, oh
wow, this is so cool.
People can just take little snippets
off from Farenthold and this
and that, you know, just
grab Chaffetz, you know,
like he's got a lot of money,
let's take some of that, you know,
oh yeah, share, free for all.
Isn't this fun, isn't this great?
But then add to it that
the people that are doing
that aren't just taking the money,
they're actually becoming rich
from it because they're gathering
the information from this thing.
I mean, it's incredible.
So, yeah, no, the musician
owns the music
if that's what-- that
was your question.
No question.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And see, I
thought it was the publisher.
>> Maria Schneider: No.
If you give the publisher--
If a musician gives the publisher
the rights and then there are,
you know, rights to kind
of administer and there's--
and some of these publishers,
there's a lot of questions
with what the publishers can do
because right now there are really,
what, a lot of composers consider to
be huge breaches because they have--
there's these organizations
called PROs
that are these performing
rights organizations like ASCAP.
Like tonight, you know,
they pay a license here.
So when my music is played in
this hall or if it's on the radio,
they collect these royalties
from restaurants and everywhere
and they divvy it out to the
people whose music there are.
Well, there's PROs, now suddenly
the publishing companies are making
these moves to try
to private license
and take these people
out of their PROs.
And there's a transparency in
the system that's been working.
And the loss of that when the
publishers start taking these--
you know, overstepping or--
you know, or if an artist gives
away those rights because they feel
that they want that advance or
whatever it is they're getting, boy,
and you lose that transparency.
Now you're settling with a
publisher that says, you know, oh,
he won't notice that he's not
getting that much royalty,
she's our new artist and we want
to make her happy, let's put--
you know, they can kind
of divvy it how they want
and you don't really know.
So, it's a very-- that's why for
me in this business, transparency
and self-ownership is everything.
I wouldn't give my music to anybody.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And
it's important that there--
that you have some kind of
consciousness about these issues,
otherwise you are at their mercy.
>> Maria Schneider: Of course.
And people are starting to wake up.
People are starting to wake up.
I think for a lot of musicians
that have these contracts,
maybe their contract, you
know, gave a record company
or a publisher whatever the
right to distribute their music
in different ways and it didn't
specify only by CD or download.
So, all of a sudden, these people--
you know, I don't know
exactly what the legal
which that people haven't
had in their contract,
but I would imagine it
wasn't specific enough.
So, all of a sudden,
these people are like, OK.
Well, you know, so if Sony,
Universal, and Warner have like 80%
of the world's music or
something close to that
and they have all these people
that have these contracts
that didn't have the specific
language that you said, you know,
it doesn't cover any-- any,
you know, method of copying
or whatever beyond the
CD and the download.
OK, all of a sudden now, these
people say, OK, now, we'll give this
to you Spotify in exchange
for equity.
And these people are
stuck, stuck on something.
The other night we did talk here
and I brought a wonderful young
musician named Spree Wilson with me.
This kid has had 45
million streams on Spotify.
And, you know, I don't
know how often they pay
if it's a quarter or whatever.
He's never had a check
for more than $60
from them, somewhere from 30 to 60.
Now, 45 million streams, I'm telling
you, that's big time, you know?
If I'm paying for $200 record
with my small big band audience,
we're talking, you know, a
mailing list of like 20,000 people
and not all of them are buying
and I'm paying for that record,
you can see what my numbers are.
Then you imagine 45 million.
So, you know, after he talked
to me, he was like, "Wow,
I think I might want to be doing
what you're doing," you know?
So, you know, we just have
to change the consciousness.
People have to wake up.
And that's what the
MusicAnswers is about.
It's like, "Hello, guys.
Let's wake up, see
what's happening."
>> Larry Appelbaum: So, you're
talking about the context
for this piece and what sort
of inspired you to write it.
Can you tell us a little bit
about the music itself and how
that animates the argument
or how that summarizes
or captures your feeling about it?
>> Maria Schneider: Well,
the music has some beauty
and it has some seduction,
you know, I think, you know?
But it has-- always underneath, the
drums are always moving fast time.
And that never stops.
So it's just this-- well,
all of this is going on,
there's always the thing here
just grabbing, grabbing, grabbing,
you know, digging, digging.
And then I'm doing a thing with
the band where I was imagining--
it's very difficult to write
music, period, let's just say that.
But it's also when you
add to it a little bit
of the [inaudible] element and,
you know, the rhythm section
and the mailability and the
exchange of ideas that can happen,
it's hard to know exactly where
those things are going to unfold,
how far they're going to go.
There's a certain understanding that
comes through performing the music,
you know, many times
that people start
to realize how far they can
stretch, what risk they can take
and keep the context of the feeling.
So, it takes a while to do that.
But I was trying to imagine
behind these solos and fathom
where they might be going
and what that rhythm,
what the drummer might feel like
if he's playing the fast time.
And I decided to create the band
that is composed out of time,
so I'm conducting everything
free over the time but I have
to listen really carefully because
I have to count where they are.
So, they're like one, two,
three, one, two, one, two,
and I'm doing these
"cha-cha-cha-cha-cha."
I have the whole band, I just
gave them like repeated notes.
And then I just look at
them and "cha-cha-cha-cha.",
cha-cha-cha-- it's kind of fun.
It kind of feels like
[inaudible], you know?
So, we're-- So it's very gestural
and I've never done
anything like that.
So, it's kind of--
it's unique that way.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And we will
hear the first performance tonight.
So, will there be an
intermission here
or are you going to do one long--
>> Maria Schneider: We're
going to do it straight.
We're going to do a
straight 90 minutes
and we're doing a variety of music.
We're playing-- Luckily this
is a pretty live strong hall,
so we're playing a couple
of real strong pieces
and then we're playing a lot of
like more-- almost pastoral--
a lot of my music from my last album
was very inspired by where I'm from,
Southwest Minnesota, wide-open
prairie landscape and kind
of that open-- he was just
saying that I didn't realize
that the premiere for
Appalachian Spring was here.
When I was a kid--
>> Larry Appelbaum:
In that same room?
>> Maria Schneider: -- that was
one of those pieces that made me --
I wore that record white.
And that was one of those records
that made me want to just, you know,
become-- you know, the small
chamber version, you know?
It made me want to
become a composer.
And for one brief period, my
sister knew Aaron Copland's nephew
or something and I
was like, "Oh, my god,
maybe I'm going to
meet him someday."
Anyway, yeah, so you'll
hear some of these pieces
that are inspired by nature.
I'm a big lover of birds.
Are there any birders
[phonetic] in here?
Oh, my god.
OK. So, migration's on.
What-- Have you seen any
warblers down here yet?
They got to be coming soon.
Your trees are green.
They're not quite like
that in New York.
I've seen the phoebes are
coming through up north.
Anyway, so, I'm very inspired
by nature and birds and things
like that, and so that's-- that
balances out the Data Lords.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I love
hearing you mention that recording
that you were out of
Appalachian Spring.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Do you
remember the first record
that you bought with your own money?
>> Maria Schneider:
"Snoopy and the Red Baron".
[ Laughter ]
>> Larry Appelbaum: By
the Royal Guardsmen.
>> Maria Schneider: It might be.
You know, I'm really not sure.
I'm trying to think if
it's with my own money.
Oh, man.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Because then
you know it's going to be important.
>> Maria Schneider:
It might have been--
It might have been "Tapestry".
>> Larry Appelbaum: Wow, really?
>> Maria Schneider: It
might have been "Tapestry".
It might have been
the "Fifth Dimension".
I don't know.
I don't remember at what point.
You know, our records, when they
were all sold in the clothing store.
What a great era?
Have any of you-- We were
talking the other day
about the Brill Building--
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: -- you know,
where the songwriters
wrote together and--
there's a wonderful book called
"All was Music in the Air".
Have any of your read that?
Great book about, you know,
the song writing collaborators
that worked in that building.
It was just such a great era
of music, you know, to come up.
And so, I don't know, I can't really
remember at what point I came of age
to actually pay for my own records.
>> Larry Appelbaum: But
you are listening to radio,
there was music around the house?
>> Maria Schneider: Records mostly.
Records. You know, it's Katie OM
Radio on Wyndham exactly, you know.
It's a town of 3,600, you know,
but I listen to a lot of records.
And then I was just
voracious going through music.
My mom had a lot of piano
music around, you know,
and everything from, you know,
a classical music she'll
pan everything.
And I just-- And then
a lot of show music.
I was really in love with the song,
you know, the "American Songbook",
Cole Porter and Harold Arlen,
and Rogers and Hammerstein.
I just absolutely love that music.
And my piano teacher really
thought me to play stride and dress
up those songs, you know?
So, she was equally appreciative
of that music as she was
in making me analyze Beethoven
and play a Beethoven sonata.
So--
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Is this Evelyn Butler?
>> Maria Schneider: This
is Evelyn Butler, yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider:
Great, great teacher.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah, I like
how you described her lesson
for teaching you about tonality.
And certain scales
or certain chords--
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: --
would represent certain
feelings again in nature.
>> Maria Schneider:
Yeah, you know, she--
the very first lesson with her--
so this is the woman she had
been stride pianist in Chicago,
classical pianist,
and really high level.
If any of you remember Dorothy
Dunnigan, I compare her to be--
and they were about the same age
and they were both from Chicago.
So, if you know Dorothy
Dunnigan, that's Mrs. Butler.
That fused kind of play
and just light the room up,
you know, when she would play.
And she was very-- I always describe
her, you know, she had red hair,
she wear [inaudible] but she has
a face of [inaudible] kind of.
[ Laughter ]
You know, she had like this-- and
kind of magnificent personality.
And my first-- And I was
very attracted with Dorothy
because I have red hair
too on top of everything.
And the first lesson she--
and I still have all my little music
writing notebooks, which I thought
of when we went to the
copyright like all the--
>> Larry Appelbaum:
The copyright deposits.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah,
the deposits and things.
But I have all these and all
the beautiful things we have
in our archive, people's
notes and things.
So I have all the stuff
and I love looking at it.
So she would play a major triad
and then sing, "Bright the day".
And then minor and
sing, "Dark the night".
And she said everything
in music is a feeling
and there's something
behind called theory.
And I want you to understand why
the music you play feels the way
it feels.
And you're going to analyze
everything you play so we're going
to have this music writing
notebook and she started teaching me
about one, four, five, one, which
is the basis of tonal harmony
that pieces start somewhere.
They go away.
They culminate and feel like
they got to go back home.
And so her thing for the one,
four, five, four was, "Here we go,
up the hill, back again home".
"Home" is tonic.
"Up the hill" is subdominant.
Dominant is-- And you
know, this is a woman
who was a professional musician.
I don't know to what
degree she studied pedagogy,
but I know something,
I don't know anybody
that ever had a childhood
piano teacher like that.
And the only reason she ended
up in Wyndham was her husband
and she had a daughter
and a son and a husband.
Her husband, his name was
Ken Butler and he had been
with the Miller Band for a while.
And he fell in love with her.
She always says because she
had been married and divorced
and she said her first
husband was lazy and horrible.
And she said she was in a bar
one night and Ken walked in
and she said she plays like a
man, I'm going to marry her.
So, anyway, he died and her son
both died in like within a month.
It was a really short period.
And her only living
family was his daughter
that had married a
chiropractor in Wyndham.
So, this woman who would never end
up in this little farm town did.
And so, you know, to my--
you know, I don't want to say
in a great fortune because it was
such a deep misfortune for her,
but it's an extraordinary thing
that I got to rush with that lady
and I will always appreciate that.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Now, clearly
she thought you about playing piano.
Did you ever gig as a
professional pianist?
>> Maria Schneider: Very little.
Very little.
A few little gigs here.
And, you know, I never had-- she
has such extraordinary technique.
And in Wyndham, everybody
thought I was amazing, you know,
but I knew I wasn't and I had
a special painful realization.
There was a farm family in--
outside of Wyndham that
had a relatives coming
to town and they invited us.
I've never been to their house,
but they're very wealthy.
And we went to this Christmas party
and they had a Steinway
in their house.
I was like, "Holy smokes."
And this family came from
the east, they're relatives
and this girl has just won
some Mozart competition.
So, after dinner, she sat down and
played her Mozart concierto and--
I mean, her runs were
flawless and I was just--
I remember just sitting there just
thinking I can kiss music goodbye.
I will never-- I will never
have that in my hands.
I just-- And with Mrs. Butler, too,
I knew I could feel my potential
for technique and I
knew I didn't have it.
I knew I love playing.
I knew I have music in me.
I dreamt of being a
composer but I felt
like it was way too lofty
of a goal, you know?
I couldn't go to college and say
I want to be a composer, you know?
Actually it took until
somebody said to me, "Hey,
you seem to have some
talent for composing."
Then it was like, "Oh, OK."
You know? I was always, you
know, waiting for the validation.
You know, I would-- I never
proceeded with confidence.
He said the other day, "You seemed
like you're very confident."
I was not at all.
I was very scared and
apologetic and, yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
I have, of course,
have many questions I
would love to ask Maria.
But I want to give you a chance.
If anybody out there has something
gnawing at them who are just dying
to know, here's your chance.
Here's a question.
Hold on. There's a
microphone right there.
>> I'm curious about your year
with Gill Adams and what happens.
>> Yeah. So I got to work-- So I
love Gill Adams so much and he was--
I would say, he was more responsible
probably for anybody, for me,
doing this along with Bob Brookmeyer
and others who I love, you know,
Dan Jones [assumed spelling],
Newt Galington [assumed
spelling] and whatever.
But there was something about
Gill's music being such--
because I told you, I grew up
loving these different kinds
of music equally.
And Gill's music, it wasn't some
of the third stream music
I always felt a little bit
like it locked like this.
Gill's music mixed idioms like
it was just water, you know?
And I love that you
could feel those lines.
And so it was dream
to study with him.
And I wanted to and in
college I wanted to apply
for a national endowment
grant study with him.
And then, one of my
teachers said "Oh, you know,
he smokes pot all the time."
[ Laughter ]
He has a [inaudible], he is
the recluse and that's just--
you know, put that dream away.
And still, I tried to call.
It was amazing back then calling an
operator on a dial phone and then,
"Gil Evans, 212, you
know, 555-1212."
And they gave me his number and I
got a message machine that's said,
"If you wish to speak to
Gil, speak after the beep."
And I got so freaked
out I hung it up.
And then, by chance I'll tell you--
and I'll tell you how
I ended up meeting Gil.
But what was funny is that-- and
that wasn't Miles Davis speaking,
it was his son whose name is
Miles who kind of talk like that
or something, I don't try to.
Anyway, the way I met
Gil I was working at--
I was working at a Xerox
machine in a music copy office.
I made my living as a calligraphy,
pen and ink, inkwell pen,
copying parts for composers
in an office in New York
for eight years, pretty full time.
And one day I was Xeroxing a score
for a composer and we got talking
and he was asking me about who
I loved and I was telling him
about Gil Evans and he was telling
me about things he was into.
And we exchanged numbers.
He was a composer who
knew people that I know
and had gone up to Eastman recently.
And he had this big dense score.
It looked very interesting.
His name is Tom Pearson.
He was in Japan now.
And then he called me that night
and he said I didn't tell you today
that Gil happens to be
like my closest friend.
And I told him about you
and he wants to meet you.
He needs somebody to assist him.
So then I got this chance to
work with him and it really--
Spree Wilson was asking me, too,
on the train coming back yesterday
after the advocacy thing.
He said, "What was it
like to work with Gil?"
And I said, pretty much like
working with Yoda, you know?
[ Laughter ]
It was just like-- It was
like being with this--
you know, this wise
old soul, you know?
And he did everything so in his
own very unique way, you know,
with his own perspective, breaking
the-- breaking rules to find things,
making instruments play on
their most uncomfortable range,
kind of like the beginning
of Rite of Spring, you know?
You know, you got the
bassoon playing this--
that's bringing out
the stride quality.
Gil was always playing with those
kinds of things that you don't--
those are the things that
make you have a voice
and that your music
just embodies you.
And so, being around
that long enough
and then also studying then
I got the endowment grant.
I study with Bob Brookmeyer who was
a whole another world equally strong
in another realm, mainly
formal development.
And between being with
these two forces,
it really at a certain point I was
like I have to start my own band
because this is-- these
people are so strong
and I realize what they are.
They are just so committed
to their own ideas,
and I have to find my own ideas
and become committed to them,
that's what I need to do
if I want to have a voice.
And so, they were very
helpful with that.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Who
else has a question?
Over here, Jay.
>> Actually, [inaudible] so
I'm going suggest you become
like a little mini data lord and
exploit the I stuff so that--
>> Use the mic, please.
>> I'm sorry.
So when these tickets go on sale,
maybe like five days before
something, you send everybody
that lives in this area little
blaster that says, "Hey,"
so that some of us who [inaudible]
to Manhattan in November to see you
at the jazz standard get a shot
at getting tickets here
not like wait until--
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah, the last--
>> That night when
you see on the Library
of Congress thing and
they're all gone.
>> Maria Schneider:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> So--
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> -- just a suggestion.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah,
these tickets went fast, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: Did
you not get a ticket?
You didn't get one?
>> Larry Appelbaum:
But he'll get it.
>> Maria Schneider: Oh.
>> Larry Appelbaum: He'll get in.
Everybody here will get in.
>> Maria Schneider: Oh,
you're going to get in?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: OK.
OK, good.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Who
else has a question?
Over here.
Over against the wall.
>> Maria Schneider:
Can I work out there?
>> Who do you listen to now?
Who do you enjoy listening
to in terms of music?
>> Maria Schneider: Oh, wow.
You know what?
It's such variety and I've gone
through so many periods but one
of my favorite things to
listen to is Brazilian music.
I love Egberto Gismonti.
He's another one where it's
like, you know, it's classical.
It's Brazilian folk.
It's like all these things
kind of mix together.
I have years where it
was flamenco music.
And then sometimes it's--
sometimes it's vocalist,
like recently just listening
to Shirley Horn just--
OK, Washington DC, Shirley
Horn, I hear you all.
I mean Shirley Horn--
I mean thank God I got
to see her sing several times
and experience her sense of time
on the piano and just
a deep expression.
And the way she would just
lay back in the communication
of that trio she worked with
that just like followed her.
And I-- you know, so anything that's
just felt so deep from the heart,
you know, I love and follow.
I suffer from one little thing in
my life and that is that I have--
this is not going sound
nice but I'm going to try
to make it sound just right.
I have so many people send me music.
And I have this feeling
sometimes that--
this obligation, because
every time--
every once in a while
you listen to something
and it's truly extraordinary.
And I feel bad not
listening to people's music
but it becomes-- it's too much.
It's so easy to record-- and I won't
say it's easy to record but it's
so many people are recording
and trying to get stuff
out there amidst all
these content, you know?
Everybody is trying to
find their way to the top.
So it's just like gorging, you know?
And so I get so much stuff that
sometimes I do want to just
like put it away and say,
"Wait, I want to just figure
out what I want to hear," you know?
My life isn't an obligation of
email and the CDs that I get
and all these things encroaching
on me, leading me until--
you know, closing in on
me but I want to find--
you know, just go on my discovery.
So, one of my things,
I'm kind of excited
about when I finish this tour,
I'm going to have some space
and I need my field to go fallow for
a while, you know, and taken music
and go to concerts-- and go to
concerts the way I used to go
to concerts like walk by
Lincoln Center and see
that picture of [inaudible].
See, I don't know who that
is but it looks interesting,
I'm going to buy a ticket.
And it changed my life.
You know, that kind of
Ouija board, fill it out.
Go in the paper.
You know, I'm going to
go to that museum today.
I don't know what's
going to happen there.
I need that my life again.
I used to live that way and
responsibility and obligation,
it pulls you away from that.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Who
else has a question?
Right here.
Yes sir.
>> Your last [inaudible]
right into my question.
We're all really fortunate
to hear the premier tonight.
But can you share what's
kind on the drawing board?
What's your future of
next project might be
or what you're thinking about?
>> Maria Schneider: I have
never been want to plan.
I've always been want to just kind
of be there and see what comes.
Even when I write, I don't
say, OK, I'm going to write
for the Library of Congress.
I want to do something
about you know big data.
You know, it's never like that.
It's sort of-- In a way,
well, I am glad I've done
that because I would have
never imagined really--
I mean, I did try to call Gil
Evans but I didn't meet him
because I tried to call him.
I would have never
thought of working
with David Bowie in
a thousand years.
And I had that just a
little bit space in my life
that allowed that to come.
But that being said, there is one
thing I dream of doing that's going
to surprise-- I don't know
if we talked about this.
It's a crazy thing.
But it involves finding
the right collaborator.
Someday I want to write a show.
Isn't that crazy?
But I do. And you know what did
it to me, I saw light on a piazza.
Did any of you see that production?
Raise your hand if you saw it.
I was so moved and
it was so beautiful.
And I just said, "Yeah,
I want to write a show."
Because I wrote songs
for Dawn Upshaw,
and the experience
of writing for words.
At first I was scared
because I thought, oh my God.
You know, it's already hard
enough just to write notes.
Now, I got to figure out I
wasn't writing the words.
I was using the poetry of Ted Cruz
but now I got figure out how to make
that fit in the context and all of
this, and there's another layer.
But it wasn't like that.
It was liberating because I love
the words and I love the sentiment.
And then that gave me the
impetus to-- it led me.
It led me.
Instead of me always having to
go into this blank space of any--
of infinity, suddenly there's this
little beacon that says here I am.
I nurture-- you know, make me,
make me come alive and
sound or something.
So, if I could find the right
story, the right collaborator,
that would be a dream of mine.
That's like the only-- otherwise,
I just want to keep developing
the sound with the band
and see what comes, you know?
Improvising life.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I actually
think we have only time
for one last question.
And if you don't mind
I'm going to take it.
[ Laughter ]
Yes. Is recognition
important to you?
>> Maria Schneider: It never
really-- you know what?
When I started this--
That's really good question.
When I started out, I never--
I thought I would be a music
copyist probably forever
and just have my band and, you know.
And I just kind of expected that and
then I thought I could also waitress
because I stopped waitressing
in Minnesota.
And I was a terrible waitress but I
figured that I could get it together
to be a New York waitress
if I needed to.
And so, I never expected
any of this.
So, I would say it's fun because
it's fun to share my music.
And yeah, it's really fun
to win a Grammy Award.
I discovered that.
And maybe it was because I remember
when I was kid once giving a Grammy
speech in my living room privately.
So--
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Into your hairbrush?
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah,
something like that, you know?
Just standing up on a stool
and I'd like to think.
But I did-- I pretended I was
Ms. America once, too, you know?
So we all did these things.
But it's-- as a musician it is
really great to be appreciated.
I will say that, absolutely.
Did I count on it and
do it for this, no.
I expected very little, actually.
So, it's just I've been very lucky.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Well, I hope
you can appreciate how many people
on this room feel that
way about you.
>> Maria Schneider: Oh, thank you.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So,
thank you all for coming.
Thank you, Maria.
[ Applause ]